[Musique]
quel odieux déballage que de cupidité
que de babioles futile d'aucune utilité
[Musique]
vite il prie tous les jouets le fit avec
ardeur une course contre le temps et
contre le bonheur
[Musique]
il y eut en chemin des obstacles
ridicule un char aux furies bas
et un shoot semblant gül
[Musique]
merci maman
voici le cadre de noël et ceci est notre
pire ennemi
vous aurez sans doute envie de l'ouvrir
et de jouer avec
il
[Musique]
mais ne faut pas si vous arrivez à
passer le cadeau de noël le seul
obstacle qui restera franchirait
le cookie ann ya le dans toute sa
splendeur rouge et sucrés non non non ça
va pas la tête de la discipline
nous allons devoir résister
aujourd'hui juste une journée
fantastique on a fait plein de choses
méchantes et on les a faites de façon
style et max tu connais le règlement toi
tu leur donnes ton lit et moi je dors
dans non non tu vas pas tu mets toi
aussi imax c'est toi qui lui a appris à
faire les yeux de chatons
bon mais que pour cette nuit
voulez-vous que je vous dise si vous
souhaitez vous excuser pour quelque
chose excusez-vous pour ceux ci ça fait
mal aux yeux
ben c'est pas à moi qu'il faut plaindre
vous n'êtes beaucoup madame le maire
veut que noël soit trois fois plus gros
cette année ce qui veut dire trois fois
plus de guirlandes trois fois plus de la
poule 3 fois plus de l'information
nécessaire ça c'est bienvenue à j'ai
compris ça y est c'est encore une de vos
plaisante t il dit pour une fois que
vous dit quelque chose de vraiment très
amusant
oui je présente très souvent mais non ça
c'était le noël 3 en tout cas ça c'est
dit on n'entend pas couramment le
ridicule vous êtes un comique la bonne
journée en voir lutter ça fait 2 123
maisons et seulement secteur d'obscurité
pour agir
nous devrons donc être rapide et très
concentré rails et moi nous serons
soumis à d'énormes augmentations
toute notre mission
[Musique]
nouveau refus
voici le cadeau de noël et ceci est
notre pire ennemi
vous aurez sans doute envie de l'ouvrir
de jouer
hélas
[Musique]
mais je ne faut pas si vous arrivez à
passer le cadeau de noël le seul
obstacle qui restera à franchir est le
cookie admirer le dans toute sa
splendeur ou g sucre et non non non non
non ça va pas la tête de la discipline
nous allons devoir résister aujourd'hui
fut une journée fantastique
on a fait plein de choses méchantes on
les a faites de façon style et max tu
connais le règlement toi tu dors dans
ton lit et je dors dans mon lit non non
tu vas pas t'y mets toi aussi max c'est
toi qui lui a appris à faire les yeux de
chatons
bon d'accord que pour cette nuit
[Musique]
joyeuses fêtes de noël
vous n'êtes plus ambitieux je sais ce
que je dois faire je vais leur volley
noël tout va disparaître
voici
le cookie il est notre pire ennemi
non non nous devons résister je vous
balance le traîneau depuis le toit
compris c'est parti
c'est la neige la plus bruyants que j'ai
entendu de toute ma vie pour devenir le
père noël je doit l'étudier et entrer
dans la peau du personnage
[Musique]
aller en piste
il
tout ça c'est des transports première
classe
oh
[Musique]
aux escanaux
m
max tu as mérité une promotion tu
tiendras montré non cette nuit
qu'est ce que max
le grinch max tu connais le règlement
toi tu dors dans ton lit et je dors dans
mon c'est toi qui lui a appris à faire
les yeux de chatons
non
bon d'accord